Hello, I'm Jonathan Worth and as well as
being a freelance photographer
I'm also a Senior Researcher at Newcastle
University's Open Lab in the UK.
The interviews you're about to hear are part of a series that along with the web platform
and connected classes, seeks to create a space for a more
critical engagement with visual storytelling.
The audio montage is of several separate interviews
of people variously representing the perspectives of the
photographer, their subject and the audience.
Our starting point today is "Fiction" as we reflect on the many storytelling devices at our disposal.
The photographer for this session unfortunately couldn't be with us.
Tim Hetherington died alongside fellow photographer Chris Hondros whilst they
were covering the conflict in Misrata,
Libya in 2011.
If you don't already know Sleeping Soldiers or Tim's Diary pieces,
then you might be familiar with the Sundance winning documentary film Restrepo which Tim co-produced
and co-directed with Sebastian Junger. Stephen Mayes knew Tim well, having first
reviewed his portfolio when Tim was a student.
He agreed to talk about his work in this interview.
Stephens own career has spanned the full gamut of photography.
From news to stock, fine art, and fashion, both as a maker and as a manager.
He is the director of the Tim Hetherington Trust, as well as writing
and commenting widely on both the
industry and the practice of photography.
Mexico City based photographer Dominic Bracco, who we'll also hear from,
was awarded the 2016 Tim Hetherington Visionary Award, and he talks to us about how,
using fiction as a storytelling device enables him to both protect his subjects and himself.
Susie Linfield is professor of criticism at New York University,
and although she only features briefly in here, there is a full conversation between her and Stephen
in the extended playlist.
Likewise there's also a deeper dive interview with the gay rights activist
Peter Tatchell who reflects on a lifetime of being the
subject of media stories that range from him being vilified to being described as
a national treasure.
[Jonathan] Stephen
[Stephen] I think what's happening at the moment is a
really interesting turning point in photography and the problem we have is
that we are trying to understand what is effectively a new medium, that works in a new way,
in the terms of the photography that we understood and knew
in the 20th century and in the first decade of this century.
But it's not. It's a different medium,
and it works a different way and to give you one example of this,
I look again at Instagram feed and there's this river of images,
this cascade of images which people stress about. [Suzan] The way that many
people get many images now, which is through their phones, which is in a very
personalized individual way, is part of this whole bubble thing. Each person can
sort of create their own world and their own reality. I'm not on like Instagram or
any of those things but my students are and I see that they just get this flood
of images all day that are totally deracinated. I mean some of them are just,
you know, their friends and their dogs and their meals but I assume that
they're also getting you know news images and different things and I don't
know how they make sense of any of that or if they do because I feel it's so
separated from context. And I'm not, you know, going back to the nostalgic days
when the whole country watched Walter Cronkite, but I do wonder if there is a
connection between that kind of individualism and the really intense and
dangerous fragmentation of the population now. And the ability that
people have to just completely x-out any news that they don't like or they don't
believe or they're not interested in. And I wonder if there's a connection between
those things.  [Stephen ] Traditionally, we have put a lot of our trust in the title of
of the magazine or the newspaper, and it increasingly was happening these days.
If the magazines and newspapers are falling into a different roles, social media is
picking up, we have people finding all sorts of ways of acquiring information
out, beyond their traditional channels. The integrity is moving on to the
journalists themselves personally, so that as a photographer, people have to
really pick up ownership of that story. It's no longer possible to hide behind
the, the editor and the title that you're working for, you have to stand up and
take that responsibility because you will be visible. In a world that's too
full of information, we, we don't properly understand the
most valuable thing is integrity, is belief in the author. You have to be
credible in a world where there's too much information that we don't
understand. It is a highly valuable position. People who have traditionally worked in
photography consider each and every picture to be precious, they have a place
in the value and need to be archived, indexed, understood et cetera et cetera.
And this doesn't really apply anymore, that people read pictures very very
quickly and they are reading from the code, they're not they're not just
looking at the content of the picture, they're looking at the, the, the
metaphorical meaning of it. So when people photograph a picture of their,
their meal and they put it on Instagram, you know a lot of professional
photographers get very dismissive of it, oh just photographing a meal, but the point is
that nobody specifically wants you to know that they have peas and carrots for
lunch, they want you to understand the circumstances they were in, and the food
becomes a terrific metaphor for where you are. So you know food becomes a code
for where I am, the access to nutrients, the social position I'm in. Usually, when
you're traveling at an airport, you know, food looks very different than if you're
at a birthday party. You know food becomes a metaphorical representation, it
becomes a coded encounter with who you are and who is your place in society.
It becomes actually very powerful. So far from being banal, I see pictures of food
as actually been very expressive, they are a metaphorical encoded
representation of who I am, how I relate to my friends, what I want
them to know about me and it becomes actually a very rich form of
communication. And more than communication, it's, it's a sharing, so you
know, communication suggests, I just sending out, I want you to note I'm
having lunch, end of story. It's not, it's not the end of the story,
you're looking for feedback at the same time, which social media does so
brilliantly. So you, you, you put out the message 'here I am, having lunch, I'm in an
airport' and people write back and they say 'cool where you going?' you know or
'I was on my way to Istanbul just last year and I was at the same restaurant'.
People share the experience, in all sorts of ways, they share it with their friends,
they pass it on, they report back to the person who posted the message. So the, the
photograph, far from being a document of memory, becomes
an actual element in current experience. So you know the photograph itself is the
experience, not the meal, curiously. But for everyone who receives the picture is
the photograph which is current and that's their, their, what we all used in
fact, in commentary and sharing with our friends. So you know the photograph
itself becomes part of the current experience, it's not documenting the
current experience, it is the current experience. And that puts the picture in
a very very different place, and looking a little bit beyond that, what you then
realize that, you know, every current experience soon turns into a memory, soon
turns into a blur, is soon forgotten and we're on to the next thing. But what's
significant is that we, we have learnt something from that and what we learned
stays with us. We learned that our friend travel to Istanbul through their picture
of the meal and we may forget what exactly the meal was but we remember
that our friend went to Istanbul or they went somewhere where was it oh yes
Istanbul, you know we can work backwards through that. So we take knowledge, we
take, you know, from the experience of sharing these imagery, we accumulate
knowledge and even though the picture itself becomes ignorable, it has enlarged us,
it stays with us, as you listen to this, you probably won't remember the exact
words that I'm using, but I hope you'll take some of the meaning with you. And
that's really the point, that's very much where we are with photography, is that
it's not to worry about each individual word, each individual image, we don't need
to do that. What we need to do is listen to the
meaning, take the meaning onboard, make it ours and move on. And that's I think,
it takes photography to a much richer place. It doesn't abandon the evidential
place that had before, the formation of record, you know the eyewitness roles
that, you know, the photograph had. It still has those values, it can
still be applied but, but, now it has this additional role which is richer,
more fluid, allows for joined-up communication not just statements, it's a
tremendous place to be with imagery.
What Instagram is doing is, it is effectively inverting all the
expectations of the image so, in Everyday Africa for example, there is a, a famously an
example of a child playing in a pool of muddy water in Africa and the, the
Instagram responses of that were of pity and concern about the poverty of this
child and the circumstances she was growing up in. What we then realized is,
it becomes an unrealistic burden on that child to represent the circumstances of
a continent but that's, that's where we've come to with photojournalism, that
we use these these codes which are really valuable, but they can also
restrict our understanding, that you know not everything is a code, sometimes it is
actually a representation. And what is happening more with this river of images
through Instagram is much more about representations, about little details of
life, which individually have very little import, you know, the woman hanging out
laundry, somebody standing in line at the bank for get some cash, these are in a
sense particularly interesting things but what happens is because it's a
stream they're not individual statements, they're part of a stream that
collectively we are listening to, we are watching a conversation about Africa.
You know all these incidental details turn out to be incredibly important and the
key here is that it moves the responsibility for understanding from
the photographer, it moves onto the viewer, you know, we are in a position now
where we have to look at what we're seeing, think about it and understand it.
And this is quite the opposite of photojournalism, where the role of
photojournalist is to exclude all that different, different information
and to focus only on the subject in-hand. The news photographer, the newspaper
photographer or magazine photographer looks at the all the chaos of the world
and they try to simplify it down to the core elements of a story they're
covering, so you're covering famine, you eliminate all the pictures of shopping
around you, because people run shops and have markets and you know even in a
famine area, these daily life happens and all you do is focus on
famine. You distract me, you exclude all the distracting information.
The notion of the photograph as a as a transient, transient experience if you
like, actually works very well for the documentary photographer and that,
although if you think traditionally of, in terms of supplying a magazine
creating a cover story all that kind of stuff, you know Instagram can be very
threatening. If instead of that you embrace the Instagram way of thinking,
you can go to a lot of very interesting places beyond Instagram, so you can turn
the picture into an experiential process which engages the imagination as much as
it tells about the facts of the situation. [Suzan] I think in this time, you're
right that I think people, journalists, photographers, activists, citizens, we
really need to think about new ways of communication and new ways of
storytelling. Not just new ways of reaching people but new ways of
understanding people's emotional worlds [Stephen] I think here of Tim Hetherington for a
number of reasons. One is that Tim in the last few years of his life started
talking about the image bank, he is talking literally about with the bank of
images that we hold in our head and the more images we see of the world, the
easier it becomes to reference the codes, you know, included in today's
picture that you're looking at. So Tim referred very much to the image bank as
being a very inclusive thing, about growing wisdoms, about accumulating
knowledge, the bank of images that we've always seen, witnessed, you shared
and have understood becomes a tool to
more rapid and more effective
communication moving forward. So, for example, if we think about sleeping
soldiers, Tim at a certain point, when he was in Afghanistan, he, he started
photographing soldiers asleep and this was in the Korengal Valley which, at that
time, had more ordnance, had more bombs and, you, know explosives loaded into it
than any other place in Afghanistan that year, a highly, highly violent part of the
world. And Tim is photographing soldiers asleep, how bizarre. But of course, there's,
there's absolutely a theory behind this and it really works, at very
visceral level, you look at those pictures of men asleep,
there, there are no guns, they're not wearing the uniforms, some of them
completely naked, but you know that there are soldiers in Afghanistan because we
have that context and immediately being to think, why are we looking at this?
And immediately you move into a kind of a metaphorical realm and what, what you
realize at a certain point is that Tim is not using a reportage here, it's not
important that at, you know, five o'clock on the Saturday
2008 the soldier was asleep, it's not documentary in that sense. It's moving
you more into a place of meditation and it's about, yes this soldier is in
Afghanistan, he is sleeping, and immediately then you moved thoughts
about vulnerability. But here's the aggressor who is vulnerable, you deal
with these contradictions, so what is that? He's a man, he's a man who was both
vulnerable, this is a picture of a man who might, as he might have been seen by
his mother, by his lover, completely other context. But he's in conflict, and we
begin to think about the role of men in conflict, that one can be vulnerable and
aggressive at the same time. Obviously there's a metaphor between sleep and
death, which has been you know a staple of literature for for hundreds of years,
it's that notion is, is what we bring to it, is what we create around that picture,
which is not factually depicted in the photograph, which becomes so interesting.
Now, if it's not factually the picture than the photograph and we're imposing
our meaning on it, is that fiction? It is a fact that the soldier is asleep, but
what we bring to it is so much richer, from our experience we are weaving in
meaning, we are weaving in significance and that's not really documentary, it's
really hard to think of those pictures as documentary, as in recording of
facts, it doesn't make it fiction but at the same time it's using stories that we
make up, it's a very interesting area to be in and it allows for a rich, rich
interpretation of the world. The Tim Hetherington trust, one of the
core difficulties we have to deal with is, we don't know what Tim would be
thinking at this point and we have no interest in speculating, we we can't do
that we shouldn't do that, but what we can do is, we can we can look for people
who are bringing similar creativity in, in their thinking to documentary work.
And this is what we do with our annual award, and in 2016 the visionary award
was won by Dominic Bracco. [Dominic] So I'm primarily a documentary photographer,
originally from South Texas and that's actually what The Backs of Men project is
about, is looking at this region that I grew up in and looking at issues of
migration and sort of the the day-to-day things that we encounter being from that
region. And then in the last seven years, I've lived in Mexico, right now I'm based
in Mexico City and I've covered cartel violence and human trafficking issues
here in the region and also in Central America. After some time of covering
those topics as a kind of a strictly photojournalist, documentary photographer,
I've started to get frustrated by the limitations of what I was doing, mostly
because before I spent a lot of time on one particular project, like, for example,
each of these things that I've done I've spent many many years like digging in
and photographing the same people, and I just didn't feel like enough to come
home with a set of 30 select images or whatever to represent what I had spent
multiple years on. I guess I just was questioning how I could do a better
justice to this story and I felt like it was always right in front of me I mean,
I studied literature in college, specifically I studied a lot of a
Mexican literature and I felt like Mexican literature actually taught me a
lot more cultural aspects of Mexico for example then, then reading any history
book or journalism piece. I've always tried to be like an intimate
photographer and I've always felt like the best way of
being true to my subjects or the people that I encountered was to try to become
very close to them. Which also poses like all kinds of issues because then as you
get deeper, you know these people become friends and those relationships change
and your objectivity changes and there's all kinds of like not real ideas about
the way journalism is supposed to work in the field. And when you're doing
projects that hopefully are more profound or deeper, you're gonna run into
all of these ethical quote-unquote ethical issues and that was kind of one
of the reasons I'd like to work with fiction is that you just don't have all
that shit to deal with. In a way, because you're not tied down by these rules that
we've designed for ourselves, quite frankly in a market, in a time that was
very different than we're living in now, you're almost able to tell a truer story
in a kind of weird way. You get into some tricky territory here because it's also
not to say that they're not worth telling, right, because those stories
are worth telling and there are obviously conflicts around the world and
there's these like darker sides of humanity that are very important and
it's always like how do you tell those and have representation and then how
does that representation fair? And the way I dealt with that previously was
just should become very close to the subjects that I photographed and like
sticking around for a long time and trying not to do like the quote-unquote
parachute journalism. But then you're also confronted with this issue once you
spend you know multiple years photographing the same folks over and
over again, it's like you have like a wealth of knowledge and information that
you just can't distill into a tiny little photo essay on a slideshow.
When you're doing these stories, people trust you and and you trust them and that's a
big responsibility, I mean, I think that, for example, if you're talking to
somebody who has committed a crime and they're being very open with you about
it and they might not necessarily understand where the story is going to be
published or run, or whatever, it can be a difficult ethical conundrum, right,
because you could get this person kill, you could get this person arrested,
maybe the circumstances of the crime that they committed are very grey and
it's not such an easy thing. And that's actually a perfect example of a place
where fiction gives you, creates latitude. Another good example is violence against
women, kidnapping and killing of women. And this is a phenomenon that's been
going on in what has been famous for it since the 90s and it's been part of the
sort of pop narrative of what is, but there was a lot of questions about what
actually happened to a lot of these girls and I covered it one of the first
open court hearings where they had just implemented this new oral testimony into
the Mexican court system in Chihuahua, it was the first state to do it. So I went
to a lot of these hearings and listened to the testimony of these folks who did
the investigation, I was able to tie in some of the details about what happened
to these girls into the fiction story of a character that I invented, based on
reality, you know, there's you know where they went, what they ate, how long they
spent, bare what happened to them afterwards, the fact that they were in
hotels or whatever. These sort of details that I got as a journalist, you know,
listening to this but then to tell a story of a person and try, to try to make
that human. [Stephen] He also, in his photography, began introducing peripheral elements,
little details about personal lives, which place these people as individuals,
and from that position allows the viewer to really identify in extraordinary ways.
It's one of the strange contradictions, is that the more specific you make a
photograph, the more people understand it. And that the problem is that if you try
to, if you try to create a generic general view of something, nobody
recognizes it, cannot, none of us none of us is generic, you know, we all have live,
we all live specific lives and we don't recognize the generic because it doesn't
exist in our lives, what we do recognize is the detail and, you know, I recognized
the place of detail in people's lives and so the more specific you become, and
the more details you include, in point of fact, the more believable the, the story becomes.
This sounds kind of contradictory because we expect more detail would
separate people but it does quite the opposite, that brings us in and it gives
us a point of reference we then allows us to fill in the rest of
the story. [Dominic ] One of the most privileged things that we have as journalists,
working in the field, is that we get to know the world from lots of different
perspectives and understand people in a way that I don't think the average
person on the street really gets to feel, because they just don't have that many
personal interactions with people from different classes, races, societies than
maybe a journalist does. Which is cool about fiction is that you can kind of go after
everyone equally, you can throw in the sort of sexism, machismo and the
racial slurs that people use and you can also like, try to create a character that
people like, that uses all those things and then all of a sudden you just feel
like a very confused and, I find that great uncomfortable space to be like a
really fun way to start conversations about culture. The drawback is obvious
and that you can create
misunderstandings or you run the risk of
misrepresenting something but I think that you run that same risk as a
journalist. It may be even more because like when you're doing it as a
journalist, you know, if you're quoting someone I mean everybody who's ever been
quoted always feels a little bit like an ass afterwards because they're like, wait
a minute, I felt, you know, we're having a whole conversation that you know brief
moment of what I said or, you know, has become the definition of who I am to
this writer. But, in fiction, you can interview somebody and then you can use
like, the fact that security guards and, and the prison, like, all really like to
eat Polish sausages on Sundays or whatever, those are like real like details,
I'm not creative enough to make up but that are even better because they're
real. Fiction also had ability to obviously blockbuster skill to move a
lot of people but it also has an ability to move people in a way that sometimes,
sometimes we can't necessarily do as strictly documentary.
(Stephen) Interestingly again, another contradiction is that by creating your fictionalized or
embellished representation of that person's life in a non documentary form,
we can actually generate a greater
trust. (Suzan) Of course there's a big difference
between fiction and untruth. Fiction can be in fact a kind of truth, a very
illuminating kind of truth. Fiction is not a form of lying, the Tim
Hetherington piece which I found very moving and very powerful, I don't know if
I would exactly call that fiction. (Stephen) Abstracting it into a fictional place
makes it, it makes it a) real because we can talk about details and things which
going on in all our lives, it makes it safe for the subject and it makes it
credible for the the viewer and in all of that there's a number of
contradictions but it all needs the same thing which is, through fiction one can
create deeper truth. Of course, the, the core here is to display where you're
coming from, that to create a fiction and pass that off as fact would be a
misrepresentation. But to say I went to
this situation and I understood what's
happening and here's what I saw, here's
what I understood, I I think takes us to
a much richer place. And I've talked elsewhere and often about Martha
Gellhorn who was working as a journalist in the 1930s, covering the Great
Depression and she eventually reported her, her experiences in the dust bowls of
of America during the Depression in the series of short novels. Having read those
novels, I now have a deeper understanding of what happened then, then I have had
from all the statistics I read, all the history books which tell me the facts of
what happened, through Martha Gellhorn I understand why people behave like that,
what pressures were on them, what, what emotional drivers put them in positions
or forced them to work in certain ways. And so you know, the fiction can lead to
a greater truth. Gellhorn didn't present those fictions
as a newspaper articles, she said these are novels based on my experience.
(Suzan) A lot of her journalism reads like short stories because she's employing a lot,
a lot, a lot of fictional techniques; character, interior, monologue,
conversation, I don't think that she was making things up, but they really read
like little short stories. (Stephen) And so context is key, and as with Dominic you know here
is a stage play, it's not a transcript of conversation, it's my interpretation of
all the conversations I've been part of, all the things I've witnessed, so I think
that you know, declaring your position is fundamental to all of this.
It comes back by the way to the notion of, you know, the integrity of the
photographer of, you know, the more exposed we are these days, we're no
longer able to hide behind other people and other production agencies, you know,
we are representing our version of the world, we have to stand behind that,
therefore identifying ourselves, not only it generates, if you like, market value for who
we are, it also generates, you know, documentary value, it, it gives us
credibility as reporters and it's that, that honesty is really core, and one
shouldn't be shy of it, one should embrace it. (Jonathan) This set of interviews set
out to address the theme of fiction in storytelling and in doing so, the
participants really dug into the nature of photography itself, they're talking
about this thing we refer to as photography as having shifted and
changed. Steven says that this change doesn't negate photography's evidential
history, but the flow of Instagram adds an experiential quality, a coded one,
where the message of the image isn't necessarily what it depicts. The language
of Instagram may denote one thing but the connotation is quite another. Just as
when we look at a picture of a heart, we know it denotes an internal organ but
the fairly universal connotation is one of love or endearment.
The Instagram food image is not necessarily a nutritional message.
Suzie talks of a need to address new and bewildering situations that require new
ways of storytelling and we might argue that as Stephen intimates??? they're already
here, we already know that the image of food shared is not just a record of our
diet. As Steven says social media is a feedback machine that invites engagement.
The airport shared lunch is the beginning of a conversation, not the end.
For many people this is going to be stating the obvious, of course it's not
about food, just like the disappearing selfies of snapchat are not meant as
record what I look like for future posterity.
For those people this might feel like a non-issue, which puts me in mind of
something the Canadian philosopher Marshall McLuhan once said: 'We don't know
who discovered the water, but we know it wasn't the fish. In other words, one
cannot understand wet if one has never been dry. Many people listening to this
will not have known a time before digital photography and social media,
a time where the published photograph did not invite a response from the audience.
But for those who do remember and who are bewildered, McLuhan had another
message. He said that anxiety is in great part
the result of trying to do today's jobs with yesterday's tools, with
yesterday's concepts. So in this ranging series of interviews and you should
investigate the extended individual recordings, Stephen and Susie begin by
discussing the ways the images are experienced through social media, what
that means for us as consumers and what that might afford us as producers.
Stephen introduces us to the work of Martha Gellhorn, Tim Hetherington
and Dominic Bracco who in turn invites us not to be tied down by rules that
we've designed for ourselves in a market and time that was very different to the
one we're living in now. They show us how consolidating a wealth of factual
experience, within fictional narratives was and is a useful and appropriate
device for the visual storyteller. Not everyone is going to agree, the use of
stock photographs in news is a related issue and it's a polarizing one, but
there are strong arguments on either side. The deep dive interview with Guy
Martin is particularly pertinent to this session, it builds on some of those
themes from a unique perspective coming as it does from someone whose path drew
very close to Tim's. Guy set the task for this session and listening to his
interview helps us to think about fiction in a more nuanced way. He pushes
us to think more deeply about some of the more performative relationships
between the photographer and the subject and also to reflect on how the tropes of
popular culture could become lenses through which we both perceive and as
photographers describe the world. Don't forget to investigate the class notes,
see why particular parts of the conversation are being responded to and
by whom, reach out and connect with people and where possible support those
who can't get into a roomful of fellow students.
My name is Jonathan Worth and you can connect with me via Twitter at Jonathan
underscore Worth.